actually instagram message requests get
that a lot
yeah you actually check them no i don't
know
every now and then just because i used
to i used to yeah i used to as well and
then i realized that these are useless
and like yeah yeah stop checking it
people just it's like throwing a coin
down a while hoping for it to grow
into a tree right it's like it's not
going to happen um
but yeah this is the stock image to go
along with it i don't really know what
is happening they're on
a carb on it yeah and definitely having
sex
i'm not really sure it's going no idea
what's going on there yeah so that's
that seems instagram messages completely
useless don't do it it's not gonna work
um unless you have a [ __ ] ton of
followers i think it pops up and the
instagram tells you
yeah yeah yeah yeah someone begs me
there's like some kind of threshold yeah
it's like having that blue tick mark on
twitter
already mentioned this one but uh just
just uh tinder yeah
i mean wait is that the
is that the same goal the in front of
the burning house it does look like it
looks like her doesn't it oh yeah it
kind of does yeah
it could be it could maybe she found a
nice career in stock images afterwards
that who knows
uh also actually believe it or not i've
been here on fiverr
of course you have no joke no of course
you know
why am i not surprised i legitimately
had a seller
sell your services
connor i've got a great deal for you let
me give you a custom offer on fiverr
all right so yeah they're actually funny
enough they already they're really good
sport about it though but they were
basically just kind of like
um i think i had hired them for one of
the videos i think they were an artist
what were they uh what what were they
trying to buy from you
no no no so i hired them yeah and then
when the video came out
they were like oh thanks for including
me in the video by i don't know if you
like want to ever like just call or hang
out
here's my discord and i'm like oh okay
all right okay
this man's an absolute chick magnet no
no this is what i'm saying right when
when you have you know you get how many
[ __ ] views we get a month on our own
like eight nine million views a month
right all it takes is one person to
think i'm attractive
why i don't know to to then go on and
then do something right i don't think
i'm inherently more attractive than
anyone or most people yeah but the thing
is
that like you should have a platform
like right but the thing is that like
i've never experienced i don't think
god's ever experienced that really
well not not to this but then i also i
also i also
but also you like i feel like your
content yeah i do videos about like
dating and stuff
yeah yeah i mean i mean like it doesn't
surprise me more appeal more to that
kind of thing
any anyone who like has because a lot of
your content base started off with
literal fan interaction
yeah yeah yeah yeah whereas for me i did
i literally didn't start
like even for most of my videos i don't
show my face i'm like yeah
whereas we don't give a [ __ ] about us
yeah you don't [ __ ] scum my whole
youtube like
career in the start was built off
interaction and i'm very grateful right
which is why like it doesn't surprise me
why some of the weirdest fan
interactions have
come from come from you i guess so yeah
that makes sense if you give avenues for
people to talk to you they'll find a way
to hit on you that's how it works
um this is the stock image uh oh my god
what is that that was me at the end of
the
figurine like true true
hey kids swallow this fish for us real
quick all right gotcha
viking kids how much are you getting
five dollars for this all right
uh next time i've been asked out if i'd
like to go drinking with someone at a
panel
uh i've had what in front of other
people in front of the whole panel yeah
i've had that
like uh two two women who are yeah i
guess
in my in my preferred demographic of you
know older women
yeah like would you like to like i'm
listening
i was like goes through his analytics
and he picks by demographic he's just
like
get rid of all this this is like 25 to
30. no
none of that too closely to 45 though oh
okay so legit i think it was uh
there there's two two women right uh
they were i think
one was the aunt and one was the mother
of the door they brought along and
she just sticks her hand up and she's
like i have no idea who you are but i
like your voice would you be willing to
have drinks with us later the mom said
that the mom said that
i've never seen a child go from like
smiling to anger so fast
the child's like mom mom
i was just like yeah i'd love to like
laugh like jokingly never did i actually
if
honestly if they came up to me
afterwards who found me at the bar i'd
have been like
okay i love talking i don't know mums
are so fun to talk to anime conventions
no not in the hitting on way just just
in general they're so
fun dude because they don't give a [ __ ]
and they're like i don't know what the
[ __ ] is happening but i'm the cool
parent
to be fair yeah to be fair when like if
it's at a signing and like a mom or a
dad
comes with their son or daughter they're
always so chill and they're like
yeah they're the best people honestly
they they they are pretty chill yeah
they are aliens trying to make it creepy
it's not
[ __ ] creepy it's it's it's it's it's
because you specifically said moms yeah
like i love talking to parents at
conventions because i'm just like dad
give me all the moms no no no i've had
like uh
wait i don't know if it comes up i'll
tell you but basically there's
one guy i've had before like his kids
really liked me he was like oh yeah can
i
buy you dinner or something i'm like oh
[ __ ] sure why not yeah yeah
we'll hang out be nice and it was nice
getting to know him and his kids so
that's cool
yeah i've had the same things with like
dads as well yeah they just
you know if if a dad's willing to like
get involved in this [ __ ] then they're a
cool [ __ ] dad yeah because i
absolutely you know when when that
happens and they they they show passion
about like what their kids passionate
about like i think they're so [ __ ]
cool
that's a good parent i wish my parents
did that because my parents didn't do
that i would never do that to this day
i i think the proudest mom i've ever uh
seen was
it was that it was at ax and you know we
had signings uh signings and then
uh two little kids come and you know
they were queuing stuff and then
the mum looks at me and she like sees my
name
and everything and she goes ask me in
thai are you thai
and then i i reply inside and then we
have this conversation and she was just
like
i am so [ __ ] happy that my kids are
looking up to a thai person
thank you for representing the thai
people i am proud of you thank you very
much i i had the opposite once in
finland where the mum was a big fan
and the daughter like the mom came up
was like
god i wish that was me yeah
so can you sign this and i was like yeah
sure and i looked at the daughter and i
was like okay
you know like what's your name i looked
at the door i was like what's your name
and the mom was like no no no it's me
and i was like oh okay oh okay because i
i feel like
for like southeast asian parents right
we we any anytime you talk to a
southeast asian parent whenever
you meet someone else usually it's the
same race every southeast asian mother
especially they go into southeast asian
mum mode right so the first thing she
legit asks me
after finding out i'm tired and just you
know asking the basic questions is
um have you had any thai food recently
because i can i can uh got a good time
you gotta have good thai food you know i
i could recommend you some places if
you're missing some thai food i'm just
like
dude i honestly i'm like thank you so
much i'm going to take this advice to
heart because honestly
and awesome honestly yes i am missing
thai food
i am missing home because i also like
moms or like parents have come up to me
and like do you want to water you look
like you're like
tired yeah yeah thank you i'll take this
oh thank you that's so kind
i've had like a dad like just slit me at
20 being like place of a beer after this
you're working you're working real hard
today son i'm like oh thanks man
oh [ __ ] i had one one time similar to
that but uh there was a actually an old
patriot of mine
uh met me and uh her grandma came and
she must've been like
70 80. not sure and she was just so
impressed that i wrote in cursive
she was like she was like like in like
the most like hick like not here it's
kind of like midwest and
kind of like oh you know it's just not
right they they teach the kids here they
don't teach them how to write cursive
it's not right i really like that you
keep the old ways alive and i'm like
because i'm just british
i've never [ __ ]
i don't know if it's that good because
no one can read my [ __ ] handwriting
yeah i mean honestly
what are your kids doing it's probably
pretty pretty good actually
yeah i also stock image i actually found
one that was fitting for this pregnant
lady with a gun with a gun
with a tiniest gun i've ever seen that's
like a that's like
that's like a bb gun that's like a a
german pistol like world war two that
looks like
well that's like the spike hide in a
post is this a scene from like
inglorious bastards or something like
this is definitely a frame taken from a
quentin county yeah yeah